people are freaked out by spiders it's
not just that they have so many
disproportionately long legs or move
erratically it's also that they have
fangs that can bite you and they kill
things way bigger than they are
yeah real spiders are scary but how
about a giant spider that could actually
eat you
meat the gyro Gumo taking the scary
spider thing to a whole other level for
centuries appearing as an attractive
woman to lure her victims to a painful
death
this giant shape-shifting spider of
Japanese folklore is both beautiful and
deadly like the real-world spider that
shares her name for now let's explore
how this deadly female monster snared
imagination in her web by taking a look
at ancient storytelling and the
mysterious world of the Japanese yokai
I'm dr. Emily szarka and this is
monstrum broadly speaking the word yokai
refers to any weird or supernatural
creature or phenomena in Japanese
folklore yokai offer explanations for
things that seem unusual or defy the
known world they are personal and
cultural shifting meaning or appearance
based on who is telling the story and
for what purpose a yokai can be pretty
much anything strange from oddly moving
smoke to head eating spirits or even a
mischievous caper umbrella the word
yokai is made from two Chinese
characters kanji that both indicate
strangeness or mystery and the word
appears in Japanese text at least as
early as the 8th century the term popped
up more frequently in the mid a'dope
Irian but wasn't really popularized as
the term for anything unexplainable
until the Meiji period a 20th century
Japanese folklorist solidified its place
in culture when he began using it in his
academic writing before yokai became the
common term for all things creepy spooky
and strange in Japan there were a whole
slew of names the name changed based on
time period and cultural popularity in
the Heian period Oni refer to anything
at knee although most often that thing
was a demon or a ger that had a
human-like shape during the Edo period
another word could be used to label any
shape-shifting being or any Appa for
more scary creature so the gyro Gumo
falls under any of these categories
since it is a strange threatening
creature that can take on a human shape
or a spider form covering all the bases
with all those legs I guess Joe DoCoMo
first appeared in literature in the Oedo
period it is highly likely that they
previously existed as part of an oral
folklore tradition the Joro
in George mo translates to prostitute
but is also associated with the word
Joro which historically referred to the
women who waited on female royalty also
known as the binding bride [ __ ] spider
and tangling bride and harlot spider
this shape-shifting creature is
unsurprisingly known for her ability to
lure handsome men into her clutches by
disguising herself as a beautiful woman
before using a painful venom to kill her
victim slowly in some stories this venom
gives the monster the ability to
shape-shift the deroga MO is said to
spin silk strong enough to capture a man
in her web and she can control other
spiders illustrations sometimes show
this creature as a woman with spider
legs or just as a large spider spiders
play a central role in a lot of Japanese
folklore the earliest known surviving
Japanese text depicting a monstrous
spider a picture scroll from the 14th
century includes a story about a
shape-shifting earth spider that first
appears to two Warriors as a beautiful
woman she tries to trap them by throwing
balls of silk webbing before they stab
her and she flees later the men find a
many-legged creature wounded in the same
area the woman was stabbed
they cut the creatures abdomen open and
almost 2,000 human heads fall out along
with spiders the size of small children
the creature is called a yamaha mo or
mountain spider in the text this seems
awfully similar to the deroga mo and it
definitely shows the association between
beautiful
women and spiders in Japanese folklore
one of the earliest written stories of
the Geronimo comes from a 17th century
text it tells of a young samurai who
takes shelter in an abandoned structure
strung with spider webs he's approached
by a young woman carrying a child who
she insists was fathered by him
the man is instantly suspicious since
the woman was traveling alone at night
in a remote place the child goes to
approach the samurai many times but
turns away each time when it sees the
man's sword annoyed and impatient the
man slashes the woman with his blade she
flees to the rafters the next morning
the samurai finds an attic where a giant
two footlong spider lays dying from deep
cuts along its back exactly like the
ones he gave the young woman a stone
grave statue of a young child is there
as well the samurai looks up and sees a
horrific sight carcasses of all the
spider woman's victims wrapped in her
web another tale from an 18th century
collection of ghost stories has a
different twist when hot summer day a
man the heir of a wealthy samurai family
relaxes and sings on his porch suddenly
a woman who appears to be about fifty
years old
approaches him she tells him that his
singing is so beautiful it's making her
daughter fall in love with him so much
so that she wants to marry him curious
to know if what the woman says is true
he follows her to a large mansion inside
he finds a beautiful woman who begs him
to consider her as his bride he declines
her offer because he is in fact already
wet both the young woman and her mother
begged him to reconsider but he remains
resolute and his devotion to his wife so
he runs from the mansion but the second
he steps outside the door it
mysteriously vanishes turning back into
the bamboo surrounding his own house his
servant insists that he has been on the
porch sleeping the entire time but
man cannot believe that what he
experienced was only a dream
suddenly he sees a female spider
scuttling away looking around he
realizes his home is strong with
numerous spider webs
even though earlier he had driven the
spiders away with his pipe smoke then he
remembered how the beautiful girl told
him the older woman had also been driven
away by smoking he orders the servants
to remove the webs and fortunately for
him the gyro Gamal never comes to him
again an attempted revenge via bigamy
and a trick to lure a man to his death
not all yokai are monsters but the
joropo certainly is
but why spiders at all you could argue
that part of the Association comes from
the cultural idea that women are out to
ensnare men with their physical or
sexual appeal or because of the
construction of the spiderweb itself
weaving spinning and other elements of
textile production where historically
areas women dominated silk weaving in
particular was an important cultural
religious and economic activity in Japan
then there's the real-life
Joro spider or Joro Gumo spider a member
of the new philia genus commonly called
a golden orb weaver in english with
their large size and unique yellow
colored silk and webs it's unsurprising
that in japan these spiders are said to
have supernatural powers some tales say
that once these spiders reach four
hundred years of age they develop
magical powers and can feed on humans
they can also shape-shift into beautiful
young women
interestingly female golden orb weaver
spiders are much larger than their drab
brown color male counterparts the
females are yellow red and black and can
be up to four times larger than the
male's of the species reaching three to
four inch wide leg spans their golden
webs can be large enough to even trap
small birds and bats given the name of
these spiders and how closely its
legends relate to the yokai my guess is
that the real golden orb weaver spider
helped inspire the original oral
folklore of the jaraguá scary lady
spider equals scary spider lady the east
asian golden orb weaver
Spyder was first discovered in North
America in 2014 which seems ironic given
that their fictional counterpart is
becoming increasingly popular here and
in other parts of the globe while long
associated with folklore in Japan yokai
have left a strong literary and visual
history when illustrated Scrolls became
popular during the Classical Heian
period yokai that largely existed as
oral stories took on visual form by
recording these unusual beings their
forms became more solidified and how
they were portrayed but the art inspired
many other different kinds of yokai as
well
today we've seen a similar resurgence as
the jor-el Gumo becomes more well known
outside of Japan the Internet in a world
that's more connected than ever made
manga and anime more popular outside of
Japan and the Douro kuhmo pops up in
both of these I'm always fascinated by
monsters that are exclusively female and
at least with the Drogo MO there might
be a good reason a reason seemingly
based on a real animal cultural and
spiritual beliefs mixed together with
the natural world weaves together a
story that is completely unique and
absolutely terrifying cool cool cool
cool cool
Kuroko the Jorah gumo fortunately the
Jarrah gumo oh my god Joro kuhmo okay
sick